[Música]
si os parece Comencemos con una pregunta
un tanto curiosa alguno sabría decirme
Cuántas elecciones se van a celebrar
este año 2024 en todo el mundo hablamos
de elecciones tanto generales como
regionales y municipales alguna idea
pues hablamos Ni más ni menos que de 76
elecciones los comicios en la India
Pakistán Rusia México Brasil y las
elecciones al parlamento europeo
llamarán a votar a la mitad de toda la
población mundial sin embargo creo que
si en algo todos vamos a estar de
acuerdo es en que hay unas elecciones
particulares que destacan por encima de
todas las demás Por supuesto estamos
hablando como no de las elecciones
presidenciales de los Estados Unidos de
América unas elecciones que podrían
terminar con el regreso de Donald Trump
a la casa blanca hoy por hoy no parece
lo más probable pero todo podría llegar
a ocurrir la inflación y sobre todo la
edad le están pasando factura a la
popularidad de Joe biden de hecho según
una reciente encuesta del Washington
post El
63 de los estadounidenses no creen que
biden esté en condiciones de afrontar un
segundo mandato Pero queridos amigos
amigas en esta ocasión no os vamos a
hablar del presidente biden hoy los
focos los ponemos Ni más ni menos que en
la figura que le acompañó hasta la
victoria la vicepresidenta camala
Harris
Porque si pensáis que la popularidad de
biden es baja eso eso es porque no
habéis visto la de Harris en especial
por noticias como estas cala Harris la
increíble vicepresidenta que desaparece
la vicepresidenta más desconocida que
podamos recordar se ha convertido en un
motivo de seria preocupación dentro de
la cúpula del partido demócrata lo es
por una simple razón necesitan que todo
sea O al menos aparente ser perfecto
para impedir que que Trump regrese al
despacho oval y aquí es donde juega un
papel especialmente importante la
vicepresidenta cala Harris Pero por qué
no se supone acaso que el papel
principal es el del candidato
presidencial Joe biden Porque muchos
consideran ya a Harris la clave para una
nueva Victoria demócrata aviso si muchos
no conocéis a camala Harris nos culpamos
lleva tiempo que parece más un fantasma
que una vicepresidenta de Estados Unidos
pero amigos con este vídeo eso va a
cambiar un poco arranquemos
[Música]
camala rompiendo
barreras cala Harris es una de esas
personas cuyo perfil parece predestinado
para la gran política de Washington hija
de una investigadora India contra el
cáncer y de un economista jamaicano
comenzó a romper barreras muy pronto ya
en 1990 empezó a trabajar en la oficina
del fiscal del distrito de San Francisco
después de graduarse en derecho en la
universidad de California Durante los 8
años que estuvo en aquella oficina
cámara comenzó a labrarse una reputación
de mujer dura su trabajo por aquel
entonces se centró en la lucha contra la
violencia de bandas el tráfico de drogas
y el abuso sexual a menores sin embargo
aquello tan solo sería el principio de
una carrera extremadamente fructífera Y
es que veréis habiendo conseguido cierta
reputación en la ciudad de San Francisco
en 2004 se convirtió en la fiscal del
Distrito en este tiempo su fama de mujer
dura se vio incrementada después de que
la tasa de condenas en el distrito se
disparara durante sus tres primeros años
quizás por eso en 2010 logró ser elegida
como fiscal general del estado de
California la primera mujer y la primera
persona afroamericana en ocupar ese
puesto Pues bien fue justo en esta etapa
cuando consiguió una gran notoriedad a
nivel nacional especialmente gracias a
convertirse en una de las principales
voces en contra de la proposición oo que
prohibía los matrimonios homosexuales y
no solo eso en 2012 consiguió uno de sus
mayores logros un acuerdo de 20,000
millones para los californianos cuyas
viviendas habían sido embargadas tras
ser Víctimas de prácticas consideradas
injustas por parte de prestamistas
hipotecarios antes del año 2007 Así que
claro después de semejante Victoria su
nombre empezó a crecer como la espuma
dentro del partido demócrata y
finalmente en 2016 centrándose en
asuntos como el aborto el aumento del
salario mínimo o la reforma del sistema
judicial se convirtió en senadora por el
estado más poblado de Estados Unidos
California fue la primera mujer indiam
mericana y la segunda mujer negra en la
historia del senado y amigos fue en esta
cámara cuando camala Harris dio el Salto
definitivo en el mundo de la gran
política lo hizo haciendo a sus
oponentes en las audiencias preguntas
muy incisivas
por supuesto con una popularidad en
ascenso sus aspiraciones políticas no se
limitarían al senado y en 2019 anunció
su campaña para conseguir hacerse con la
nominación del partido demócrata en las
presidenciales del 2020 Harris quería
convertirse en la rival directa de
Donald Trump sin embargo la falta de
financiación y una serie de errores
cometidos durante la campaña hizo que su
estrella que empezó Pisando fuerte en
las primarias acabara pagando sin
embargo Joe biden tras ser nombrado
candidato demócrata y quizás tras el
conflicto y la tensión producida con el
asesinato de George Floyd tomó esta
decisión la vicepresidenta elegida por
Joe biden camala Harris y así finalmente
tras la derrota de Trump en 2020 el 20
de enero de 2021 Harry se convirtió en
la primera mujer y persona afroamericana
y de origen indio en ocupar la posición
de vicepresidenta de los Estados Unidos
En aquel momento muchos la veían como la
Clara heredera de biden Sin embargo
estos últimos 3 años han supuesto todo
un frenazo para la carrera estelar de
Harris tan desaparecida que hoy muchos
se preguntan Quién demonios es camala
Harris Así que la pregunta es qué
diantes ha pasado Pues bien veámoslo
Harris en
decadencia seamos justos son pocos los
casos en los que se recuerda a los
vicepresidentes de estad Unidos pocos
muy pocos han logrado ser recordados al
cabo de unos cuantos años sin embargo
con cala Harris se había generado cierta
expectativa de que esto no fuera así se
esperaba un giro de 180 gr en la
vicepresidencia se pensaba que tendría
un gran peso dentro del gobierno Pero
por desgracia para ella eso no ha sido
así Harris llegó a Washington pensando
en ser la nueva Dick chiny moviendo
hilos a su antojo y terminó siendo más
bien Selina Meyer si no habéis visto VIP
no sé a qué estáis esperando A
diferencia de algunos ex vicepresidentes
demócratas como al gore con Bill Clinton
o Joe biden con Barack Obama o incluso
el mismo Dick chany con Bush hijo
republicano que lograron tener bastante
influencia en El Ejecutivo Harris no ha
sido capaz de lograr tener su propia voz
Eso sí Muchos analistas defienden que
Harris ha cumplido estrictamente con lo
que normalmente se espera de un
vicepresidente que no es otra cosa que
no hacerle sombra a su
presidente
tradicionalmente el puesto de Vice de
VIP no ha sido ni el más brillante ni un
gran trampolín de hecho en los últimos
50 años Solo dos vicepresidentes luego
fueron elegidos presidentes George Bush
padre y el propio Joe biden bueno Y
luego tenemos a gerald Ford que llegó al
despacho Val de rebote Así que para
muchos la ausencia no resulta tan
extraña sino algo Bastante normal bajo
esta perspectiva camala podría haber
cumplido con lo que se esperaba del
puesto de hecho pese a a esa aparente
ausencia Harris ha sido clave para la
administración biden en repetidas
ocasiones especialmente en el senado
Donde ha roto bastantes empates camala
Harris bate el récord de votos de
desempate en el senado la vicepresidenta
ha aportado el voto decisivo en el
senado en 32 ocasiones en un reflejo de
la estrecha mayoría demócrata y de la
polarización más amplia de la política
de hecho su voto de desempate fue
absolutamente decisivo para sacar
adelante una de las principales medidas
de la Administración biden el plan de
estímulo económico tras la pandemia de 2
billones de
dólares además también ha logrado que
todos los candidatos del presidente
biden sean confirmados tanto en el
congreso como en el senado algo que ha
resultado clave para hacer avanzar la
agenda del gobierno y por si fuera poco
Harris ha jugado un papel más importante
del que nos podría parecer a primera
vista en la política exterior de la Casa
Blanca por ejemplo en estos 3 años a ha
visitado casi 20 países y se ha reunido
con más de 100 líderes mundiales de
hecho Harris no solo fue clave para
normalizar las relaciones diplomáticas
con Francia en 2021 sino también fue
quien a principios del 22 avisó al
propio zelenski de la inminente invasión
rusa de Ucrania sin embargo toda esta
actividad se ha quedado en nada en
comparación con la percepción pública de
estar desaparecida y con el aluvión de
críticas que ha recibido desde su
nombramiento y para muchos este mal
desempeño político ha tenido mucho que
ver con su
ambición por ejemplo tan solo 6 meses
después de asumir la vicepresidencia se
le criticó por no haber querido visitar
directamente la frontera Sur para
impulsar medidas que aliviará la crisis
migratoria digamos que camala Harris no
quería mancharse con esos temas luego
tras su sonoro fracaso en la entrevista
con el periodista Lester Holt de la nbc
para explicar la situación la confianza
en ella se desplomó para noviembre de
2021 su índice de aprobación se situó
tan solo en un 28 por convirtiéndose así
en una de las vicepresidencias más
impopulares de la historia además a
Harris también le han perseguido ciertas
acusaciones por supuestamente crear en
torno a ella un ambiente laboral
extremadamente tóxico rozando casos de
acoso y muchos ligan esta situación a la
renuncia de piezas claves en su equipo
durante el primer año y medio de mandato
por si fuera poco Harry ha protagonizado
algunos momentos especialmente
embarazosos en actos públicos donde las
frases con poco sentido se han llegado a
hacer virales lo que por supuesto la
oposición ha explotado con el fin de
ridiculizar su figura y todo esto
explica por qué la aprobación de Harris
a lo largo del 2023 se situó tan solo en
el 32 por. sin embargo en los últimos
meses su equipo y ella misma se han
propuesto un objetivo relanzar su imagen
ante un factor clave en estas elecciones
de 2024 la zada edad del presidente
biden
atentos la clave
demócrata a finales del mes de abril del
2023 biden anunció finalmente su
decisión de presentarse a la reelección
junto a él como era de esperar Se
mantendría camara Harris El problema es
que si esto se produce la campaña
electoral estará dominada por un tema
muy concreto la edad de Joe biden Y es
que veréis de ser reelegido biden se
convertiría en el presidente electo más
anciano de la historia del país con 82
años Así que muchos ya dudan de la
capacidad Real del actual presidente de
completar un segundo mandato que
teóricamente terminaría con la friolera
de 86 años precisamente por eso todos
los focos están esta vez fijados en
camala Harris de hecho desde el partido
republicano ya lo dicen alto y claro un
voto para el presidente biden es un voto
para la presidenta Harris y esa es
exactamente la misma razón por la que
Harris y su equipo llevan trabajando
intensamente en los últimos meses para
intentar mejorar la percepción pública
de una de las vicepresidencias más
impopulares de la historia Claro que no
es algo estrictamente
nuevo fue ya en junio de 2022 cuando
Harris vio la oportunidad de volver a
relanzar su imagen tras la derogación de
la doctrina Row contra wt por parte del
tribunal supremo lo que provocó la
eliminación del derecho al aborto que el
propio tribunal había sostenido Durante
los últimos 50 años Pues bien la
vicepresidenta Harry se convirtió en una
de las principales voces contra esta
decisión y acabó siendo crucial a la
hora de explotar este caso en favor de
los demócratas eso mejoró su imagen pero
no fue suficiente por eso en el último
año ha estado realizando un tour por
diferentes universidades del país para
afianzar el voto joven con una agenda
centrada en asuntos como el propio
aborto el medio ambiente o los derechos
lgbt al mismo tiempo Harris ha ido
elevando de nuevo su faceta más
combativa y lo cierto es que los datos
parecen decir que el plan le está
funcionando su imagen dentro del partido
demócrata ha mejorado y muchos lobis
parecen volver a apostar por ella Harry
recibe su caballería los principales
grupos gastará más de 10 millones de
dólares para apoyarla nson afirma que
Harris es sin duda la mejor opción para
Además no es solo que Harris esté
mejorando su imagen sino que esta vez la
historia puede estar de su parte si los
republicanos insisten en atacarla con
todo Harris no puede cantar Victoria tan
fácilmente pese a todos los esfuerzos
realizados su nivel de popularidad sigue
por los suelos Y para colmo la
vicepresidente arrastra una profunda
mancha la crisis migratoria en la
frontera con
México y Es que veréis desde la llegada
de biden y Harris a la Casa Blanca en 21
el número de encuentros con inmigrantes
en la frontera con México ha estado
creciendo exponencialmente hasta superar
los niveles récord de hace más de 20
años de hecho tan solo entre octubre y
diciembre del 23 730,000 inmigrantes
fueron detenidos justo en la frontera
con México y desde luego noticias como
esta nos indican que la presión parece
ir solamente en aumento la Caravana
masiva de igrantes que se dirige la
frontera entre Estados Unidos y México
es la más grande en más de un año puede
llegar a 100000 personas según advierte
un activista desde la oficina de la
vicepresidenta que ha sido precisamente
la responsable de la política migratoria
en la administración biden se ha
intentado hacer frente a esta crisis
centrándose en la mayor fuente de esta
migración masiva el denominado triángulo
Norte El Triángulo Norte se refiere al
espacio conformado por Guatemala
Honduras y El Salvador y os hemos
contado aquí en visual politic en varias
ocasiones las duras condiciones de vida
que existen en estos países pobreza
inseguridad corrupción no es de extrañar
que sea una de las principales fuentes
de migración hacia Estados
Unidos Pues bien la vicepresidenta
Harris ha impulsado la denominada
estrategia de Estados Unidos para
abordar las causas principales de la
migración centroamericana una estrategia
dotada con 4200 millones de dólares
tanto públicos como privados con la que
se busca mejorar las condiciones de vida
de estos tres países para desincentivar
así la inmigración junto a ello desde la
administración biden también se han
celebrado varias reuniones con el
presidente mexicano amlo para involucrar
más a este país y se ha reforzado la
financiación de la seguridad fronteriza
sin embargo parece evidente que estas
medidas por el momento no están
surtiendo ningún efecto entre otras
cosas porque cambiar la realidad
socioeconómica de varios países es un
proceso de muchos años y Porque tampoco
es que la ejecución del plan parezca
haber sido la mejor además los
estadounidenses quienen resultados
rápidos ante lo que se ha convertido Ni
más ni menos que en una una de sus
mayores
preocupaciones esta crisis migratoria
junto con la crisis de la inflación son
con mucha diferencia las dos grandes
bazas para las aspiraciones de Donald
Trump de hacerse con la casa blanca y
son en gran medida lo que explica
noticias como estas Trump lidera en
cinco estados críticos mientras los
votantes critican a biden según una
encuesta de Times Siena golpe a biden un
sondo da ventaja Trump para las
presidenciales de 2024 Trump aventajar
por 47 por a 43 lo que ocupa a algunos
demócratas mientras otros advierten que
hay que evitar la enfermedad loca de las
encuestas así que ya lo veis camala
Harris la vicepresidenta que llegó
rompiendo todas las barreras puede
llegar a jugar un papel clave en la
reelección tiene la juventud y la
energía potencial que quizás le falte a
biden después de un difícil comienzo y
la de ble de su imagen política Harris
quiere recuperar terreno para lograr
hacerse con el objetivo más codiciado
por todos los políticos de Washington el
despacho oval pero llegamos a este punto
el turno ahora es para todos vosotros
creéis que Harris es la verdadera clave
para la reelección demócrata Cómo puede
hacer frente esta administración a la
grave crisis migratoria en la frontera
Sur será esta crisis la que aupe
nuevamente a Trump a la presidencia
podéis dejarnos vuestras respuestas en
los comentarios como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visual politic sacamos
vídeos nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribios a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]
i